[Música]
economía quien directo a América edición
nocturna me acompañan el estudio Jorge
Hurtado Jorge muy buenas noches
comenzamos hablando del Banco Central
europeo que subió los tipos medio punto
hasta el 3% y adelanta de nuevos los
aumentos de este 2023 bueno conecto el
precio del dinero llegó a máximos desde
el 2008 se trata del quinto aumento
consecutivo que efectúa la institución
en apenas medio año de hecho el consejo
de gobierno aseguró que en marzo
efectuará Un aumento de medio punto más
los mercados financieros interpretaron
la medida como una sugerencia de que el
ciclo de endurecimiento de la política
monetaria podría terminar pronto al
igual que lo hicieron ayer después de
que el jefe de la reserva Federal de
Estados Unidos
dijera que había indicios de que la
inflación estaba remitiendo el Banco
Central europeo sube los tipos a un
ritmo récord para luchar contra la
subida de los precios una de las
secuelas de la pandemia y también de la
crisis energética que siguió la invasión
de Ucrania por Rusia hace casi ya un año
el fondo monetario internacional instó a
los bancos centrales del mundo a
comunicarla la probable necesidad de
mantener Estos tipos de interés más alto
durante más tiempo para que la inflación
vuelva a situarse de forma sostenible en
el objetivo pasemos a hablar ahora de
los 100 primeros días de gobierno del
Primer Ministro británico
Cómo le ha ido en ese manejo de la
economía británica bueno bastante
compleja la situación en Reino Unido
luego de heredar El pánico por los
recortes Fiscales de su predecesora list
suena calmó los mercados financieros y
evitó el colapso económico tras asumir
el cargo de Primer Ministro el 25 de
octubre prometió controlar la inflación
conseguir el crecimiento económico
aliviar la presión sobre el sistema
sanitario y devolver la integridad a la
política tras años de escándalos pero
hasta hoy el producto interno bruto
sigue siendo menor que antes de la
pandemia y el fondo monetario
internacional pronosticó esta misma
semana que el Reino Unido será la única
gran economía que que se contraerá este
año un
0,6%. es una culpa de esta situación a
los efectos de la pandemia y la guerra
en Ucrania pero algunos analistas
señalan al brexit que ha provocado una
fuerte reducción del comercio entre
Reino Unido y la Unión Europea el Primer
Ministro enfrenta una oleada de huelgas
enfermeros paramédicos profesores
agentes fronterizos y otros trabajadores
que buscan aumentos salariales para
compensar esta subida en el costo de la
vida hablemos ahora del negocio del gas
porque le dio a shell el mejor resultado
de su historia para el año 2022 Cómo les
fue entonces bueno la empresa reportó un
incremento del 110% en las ganancias
anuales el año pasado shell generó
ganancias por
42.309 millones de dólares sus mejores
resultados en 115 años de historia de
esta compañía el aumento de precio de la
energía provocado por la guerra en
Ucrania las petroleras y gasticas
también hacen frente a impuestos
adicionales en algunos países para
tratar de compensar esos beneficios
extraordinarios esos impuestos
representaron para shell 1500 millones
de dólares en Países Bajos Alemania e
Italia en mercados en esta llamadas
contribuciones solidarias impuestas por
la Unión Europea y otros 900 millones de
dólares también en Reino Unido de cara
2023 shell tratará de aprovechar y
ampliar la posición de Liderazgo Global
en el sector del gas natural licuado y
otros derivados según dijeron a través
de un comunicado pasamos ahora a otro
tema metas Se dispara en la bolsa más de
un 25% porque bueno Esto principalmente
por el anuncio de la recompra de
acciones y los recortes de gastos la
subida de hoy es la segunda mayor en la
historia bursátil de esta compañía que
es dueña de Facebook Instagram y
WhatsApp los inversores ven con buenos
ojos los objetivos de recorte de gastos
de la empresa y el plan de recompra de
acciones ambos fueron presentados con
los resultados de cierre del 2022 que
mostraron también la primera de ingresos
en la historia de meta es importante
señalar que buena parte del ahorro de
meta proviene del despido de 11.000
trabajadores que Zuckerberg anunció en
noviembre del año pasado y pasamos ahora
a hablar de Apple que registró su
primera caída trimestral de ingresos en
casi cuatro años qué les pasó bueno Esto
luego de que las restricciones impuestas
a sus fábricas en China por la pandemia
limitarán las ventas el último iPhone
durante la temporada navideña la las
ventas en la empresa sumaron 117 mil
millones de dólares en el período
octubre y diciembre y se pusieron
también un descenso del 5% respecto al
mismo periodo del año anterior una caída
mayor de lo que previan ya los analistas
las ganancias ascendieron a 30 mil
millones de dólares o uno coma 88
dólares por acción eso es un 13% un
Trece menos que en la misma época del
año anterior esos resultados también
incumplieron el objetivo del uno coma 94
dólares por acción que se habían fijado
a pesar del descenso trimestral de su
fortuna Apple aún ninguna intención de
recurrir a despidos masivos en contraste
con sus pares de las grandes tecnologías
Muchas gracias Jorge por esta
actualización del mundo de la economía a
continuación aquí en directo América
ponemos la lupa en el referendo de
Ecuador en el debate a continuación